animal life just even having  multicellular life took a really long  time so life let the level of  single-cell things you know might be  extremely common but animal life might  be rare rare and then it took a long  time to develop ur you know conscious  conscious beings being technology bang  rockets as opposed to conscious you know  so so animal you know multicellular life  that makes animals might be rare and  then technology might be even rarer yeah  that's a good way to put it on the other  hand there's a lot of stars exact so do  I have an opinion I'm just gonna say no  I don't have an opinion but I wonder  about these things I was just talking